[Music]
the corona virus pandemic is a global
crisis that requires a global response
no single nation can be expected to
solve it an international cooperation is
more important now than ever my name is
Tim and I'm an early stage research
within the MSC a honours ITN our
international group of researchers was
set up to prepare for viroid breaks just
like the one we're going through right
now we're all working hard to find out
everything we can about this virus and
come up with solutions to stop it but we
ourselves and researchers all over the
world are working with limited resources
we need more resources to continue the
fight because after we've won this
battle we must prepare for future
pandemics whether they're corona viruses
or other infectious diseases because
there will be more pandemics and
investing in fundamental research and
training researchers is key to reduce
the impacts of future dynamics the
owners itn motto has never run more true
than now because preparedness needs
training